Now, first things first.
Just in case you aren’t yet familiar with
SCP-049, otherwise known as the infamous Plague
Doctor, then we’re here to bring you up
to speed.
It’ll help you get the most out of today’s
tale.
SCP-049 is a tall humanoid entity, always
seen wearing long black robes, a hood over
its head, and a beaked mask protruding from
underneath, the same kind of mask worn by
physicians during the height of the Black
Death.
However, these parts of the Plague Doctor’s
attire aren’t just a costume; the SCP Foundation
discovered that all of SCP-049’s outfit
is actually part of his physical body.
In other words, the robes, the hood, the mask,
they are all made out of muscle and bone.
The Plague Doctor’s only real goal in life
is to hunt down any person it deems to be
“infected.”
The entity often refers to something he calls
“The Pestilence”, and upon sensing this
affliction in a human being, SCP-049 will
attempt to make direct skin contact with whoever
is apparently carrying said pestilence.
The Plague Doctor’s touch is lethal, killing
anyone he comes into contact with.
You might think that’s as bad as it gets,
that this creature just goes from person to
person, killing them via touch.
But you would be wrong, it gets worse.
Killing one of his victims is only the start.
Afterwards, SCP-049 then begins performing
a crude, outdated form of surgery, defiling
and repurposing the person’s corpse.
Using equipment that he produces from his
iconic doctor’s bag, he injects a number
of unknown chemicals into a person’s carcass,
eventually turning them into an instance of
SCP-049-2.
In essence, a vicious, incredibly aggressive
zombie.
The most bizarre part is, in SCP-049’s mind,
this means he’s just cured you.
Naturally, SCP-049 is already held in containment,
safely locked away by the SCP Foundation.
At present, SCP-049 resides in a humanoid
holding cell, closely monitored by surveillance
cameras for twenty-four hours a day, every
single day.
The SCP Foundation used to send its doctors
and researchers into SCP-049’s cell, or
would make a habit of bringing him cadavers
as test subjects: fresh bodies for the Plague
Doctor to hone his surgical skills.
The researchers would keenly observe the doctor
transforming the dead into instances of SCP-049-2.
But these researchers and doctors working
for the Foundation weren’t exactly free
of disease, meaning every time they entered
SCP-049’s cell, they were at risk of receiving
his deadly touch.
In this cage, with this deadly, dangerous
doctor that spends all his time in captivity,
that’s where our story starts.
But while you might expect a story about the
Plague Doctor to revolve solely around violence,
disease, and death, this tale offers a surprising
divergence.
Boiled, Scrambled and Fried is a story about
an unexpected new life coming into existence
in a frankly bizarre fashion, all starting
in that tiny containment chamber where SCP-049
had been held since the Foundation first captured
him.
It had become increasingly obvious to the
researchers observing him that something was
quite wrong with the Plague Doctor.
For the first time since the doctor had arrived
in the Foundation’s custody, he appeared
to have fallen ill unexpectedly.
The security cameras that were trained on
him day in and day out recorded SCP-049 groaning
in pain, clutching his stomach as he limped
weakly around the confines of his cell.
Had the pestilence finally gotten the better
of the good doctor?
Was he too now infected, the same as the world
around him?
The Foundation’s medics were confused, baffled
as to what could possibly be wrong with the
creature.
Of course, it would have been easier to examine
the doctor if they could easily touch him
without the risk of dying, or if his body
wasn’t made of skin robes.
Nonetheless, the Plague Doctor was brought
to a medical station for a proper diagnosis,
under the orders of one Doctor Richard Omel,
a Foundation doctor who specialized in taking
care of humanoid anomalies, and who had been
assigned as SCP-049’s caretaker.
The creature tried to assure Doctor Omel that
he was strong enough to withstand the intense
pain he was obviously suffering from.
Putting on gloves for safety, Doctor Omel
felt a distinct lump within SCP-049’s stomach,
initially believing it to be a case of abdominal
distension.
This is a condition that occurs when gases
or fluids build up in the stomach and cause
it to swell up and inflate, usually as a symptom
of another internal disease.
But SCP-049 reassured his caretaker that his
condition wasn’t the result of any disease,
and in fact, it had even apparently happened
before.
Doctor Omel asked SCP-049 why he had never
told the Foundation about this, or why the
creature wouldn’t explain what was happening.
“I did not think you would believe me, so
I said nothing,” SCP-049 explained.
“Doctor…
I’m pregnant…
I’m sorry, but I can’t explain it.
Please, just let me return to my cell.
I need to make the proper preparations.”
Naturally, this statement was met with stunned
disbelief by Doctor Omel, especially seeing
as the Foundation had been observing SCP-049
through security cameras for months on end
without stopping.
The creature couldn’t explain, tensing up
and breathing heavily due to suffering obvious
and intense pain.
As Doctor Omel rushed out to grab more members
of medical staff, the Plague Doctor continued
struggling against the aches, letting out
his loudest of cries yet, as an extreme bout
of agony surged through him.
A pearly white egg gently tumbled out from
SCP-049’s robes just as Doctor Omel and
a group of Foundation medics arrived, staring
in shock at what had just happened.
Seeming to recover quite quickly, the Plague
Doctor asked to be unshackled and returned
to his cell to tend to his egg, worried it
would die unless he was able to care for it.
As the shocked Doctor Omel agreed, SCP-049
gently picked up the egg and cradled it in
his arms.
Of course, this all came as quite an unexpected
turn of events to the Foundation, reports
were filed and archive entries had to be updated.
But, they allowed the Plague Doctor to keep
his egg and raise it, perhaps just so they
could watch and research as it happened, instead
of out of any sense of kindness.
For the next five days, the creature was fixated
entirely on caring for the egg, all his energy
focused on it.
He built a nest in the corner of his containment
cell out of fabric and paper, and would sit
on the egg in order to keep it warm.
During that time, a number of Foundation researchers
assigned to watch over SCP-049 reported that
they had heard clucking noises coming through
the speakers in the observation room.
Now assigned to watch and report on SCP-049’s
progress, Doctor Omel watched the Plague Doctor
from the observation room connected to the
cameras and audio recording devices in the
creature’s cell.
Ever since the bizarre and unanticipated birth,
Omel had been given the task of compiling
an extensive report on everything that took
place within the cell.
For the most part, everything seemed fine,
or as fine as something so unusual could seem.
The egg was in a healthy condition nonetheless,
although the whole event had the Foundation
doctor wondering.
SCP-049 had always had a somewhat bird-like
appearance, helped in no small part by that
infamous beak-shaped mask.
Did the fact that this creature could apparently
lay eggs mean that the Plague Doctor was some
form of humanoid bird?
An avian human hybrid that only mimicked the
plague doctors of old?
Or had those medieval physicians created their
masks to emulate SCP-049?
Which had come first, the plague doctors or
the Plague Doctor?
A debate as confusing and cyclical as the
one about the chicken or the egg, and now
the plague doctor also has an egg.
I don’t know about you, but I’m starting
to get a headache just thinking about it.
SCP-049 had begun to softly peck at the surface
of the egg, when Doctor Omel decided to step
in and look for some answers to his burning
questions.
Over the speakers in 049’s cell, he asked
for an explanation.
The Plague Doctor answered that he was checking
his egg for signs of life within its shell,
as if that answer should have been obvious.
And he had succeeded, there was definitely
something living inside.
As the Plague Doctor returned to sitting atop
the egg, Omel asked outright if SCP-049 was,
in fact, a bird.
It was uncommon, if not downright unheard
of, for a humanoid anomaly to lay eggs like
this.
After a moment’s thought, SCP-049 replied
with “No, as far as I’m aware, I have
never been a bird.
Yet, producing eggs is natural to me.”
He explained that, while this had happened
before, it had at least been a few decades
since the last time.
Then, the Plague Doctor went back to sitting
on his egg, humming as it rocked back and
forth in the nest.
Ten days passed after the egg had first arrived,
and now SCP-049’s cell was brimming with
activity.
Foundation personnel had fitted the room with
a glass screen to protect them from the Plague
Doctor, with researchers piling into the safe
side, carrying cameras and hurriedly taking
notes, protected by a number of guards.
The big day had seemingly arrived.
Whatever had been brimming and brewing inside
that egg was about to hatch.
As the researchers all whispered to each other
with excitement and intrigue, SCP-049 stood
protectively on the other side of the room,
just waiting in fascinated expectation.
The pearlescent egg started to shake suddenly,
its pale surface cracking.
The crack spread from the center of the egg,
forking across the shell like a lightning
bolt over a dark, cloudy sky.
Something underneath was pushing through,
pressing outwards from within the egg, splitting
it apart as it tapped and pecked its way to
freedom.
A small, white beak poked a hole through the
shell that surrounded it, piercing the egg
at last.
The creature within, this spawn of the Plague
Doctor, began to tear itself through the barrier
that had kept it safe from the outside world
until it was ready to take its first steps.
With both arms, the thing tore itself out
of the egg, all under the watch of the Foundation’s
doctors and researchers, who were stunned
to see…
Another Plague Doctor emerging from the egg.
It was small, much, much smaller than the
father that had birthed it and cared for it
while it was waiting to hatch.
But, it was nonetheless a perfect miniature
version of SCP-049, complete with the same
kind of robes, the same beaked mask, even
with a little hat on top of its head.
With a gasp of pure excitement, the original
Plague Doctor lifted up his new mini self
and hugged the child in his arms.
The excitement that had filled the room up
until now quickly dissipated, as the audience
of Foundation personnel quickly realized they
had just witnessed the live birth of a brand
new anomaly, of which they understood virtually
nothing.
As Doctor Omel stepped forward to cautiously
ask SCP-049 to put down its offspring, the
smaller Plague Doctor smacked Omel’s hands
with a stick, before leaping from its father’s
arms and dashing out of the cell.
As the alarms began to blare, indicating a
breach in containment, SCP-049 wiped a tear
from his eye, stating “He… is the cure.”
The new, smaller plague doctor, now designated
as SCP-049-J, seems to have a talent for evading
capture by the Foundation, and for frequently
escaping containment.
Unlike its predecessor, SCP-049, this offspring
has a body beneath its robes that is composed
mostly of moss, wads of tissue, and smaller
plague doctor masks.
During the occasions in which it has been
successfully detained by the Foundation, SCP-049-J
has claimed that it is in fact a powerful,
magical doctor and wizard, with the ability
to cure all that ails mankind.
However, to date, it has been unable to cure
anything, usually making medical conditions
actively worse.
My headache included.
Now go check out “SCP-049 - the Plague Doctor
Captured” and “SCP-049 - What Actually
is the Pestilence?
The Plague Doctor Questions and Theories”
for more on the not-so-good-doctor!